Dwayne Johnson's mom Anna Johnson was
involved in a car crash Wednesday night
one that left her vehicle totaled but
thankfully the actor says mom is okay
the rock shared the news on Instagram
Thursday posting this snap of The Red
Cadillac his mom was driving when she
got in the accident the SUV's front
passenger side completely crushed but
thankfully the former WWE star says his
mom made it out unscathed noting in the
caption she has a history of making it
through challenging situations lung
cancer a tough marriage a head-on
collision with a drunk driver and an
attempted suicide she is a survivor in
ways that make angels and miracles real
I'm really blessed extremely fortunate
the actor thanked the Los Angeles police
and fire departments for being so caring
and focused and for staying on the phone
with him and talking him through it all
let's not ever take it for granted
Johnson whose dad pro wrestler Rocky
Johnson died in 2020 wrapped up his post
writing that he has one parent left and
urged fans lucky enough to have both to
give them a hug he passed away suddenly
and we had a complicated relationship
that was full of tough love but there
was love there you never know when
you'll get that 3 A.M call we never want
to get it always comes down to family
back in 2021 Johnson surprised his mom
with a Cadillac SUV but it wasn't the
car involved in Wednesday's crash at the
time he shared this snap on Instagram
writing that she was shocked and
overcome with pure joy I'm so grateful I
can do this kind of stuff for my mom
who's had one hell of a life family is
the most important thing but the Rock's
generosity hardly stops there for
Christmas 2018 he gave Anna a brand new
house this Willy Wonka golden ticket is
good for
12 18.
wait wait wait wait
a brand new home in the caption Johnson
explained that when he was young they
moved from apartment to apartment as his
parents tried to make ends meet and it
felt good to tell his mom she could
choose any home she wants anywhere she
wants quote I always say if you've got a
good Mama then you got a pretty good
shot at becoming a decent human being
before adding that he's lucky to be able
to make stuff like this happen Merry
Christmas
foreign
[Music]